and we are recording so what's going on
everybody
so we're gonna do a slightly different
uh episode of richard on data today i'm
joined today by none other than
i'm gonna attempt not to butcher the
pronunciation of the name
also known as the data professor
so we're coming together today to talk a
lot about some of the differences
between academic data science and what
you may
do in industry and luckily shannon comes
to us here with
i think 15 plus years of experience in
academic data science just with data
science
in general so i hope you guys will
appreciate his perspective today
so shannon thanks for coming uh coming
on board to my channel today
um i would imagine there's an enormous
amount of overlap
in you know your audience and my
audience but
for those who follow me but haven't seen
your channel or heard of your channel
could you start off just
telling tell us all about your
background and
just what you've done thus far in data
science to the extent it's been
involved in academia as well as in uh as
well as an industry as well
okay sure yeah so first off uh thanks
richard for having me here
uh for this awesome discussion so a
little bit about my background
so i have a bachelor's in biology
so quite uh non-technical and
i have uh came across data science
during the course of my phd studies
and it was about in my second year that
i was
acquainted with a uh a newly graduate
phd graduate from the us so he
he just got his phd in data mining and
then
we met and then he gave me this book
artificial neural network for drug
discovery
and then we had an initial discussion
and then other than that he was quite
busy
so then i kind of self-taught myself
data mining and the first program that i
was using was called weca
it's a java based graphical user
interface for doing data mining
so you could essentially click sub
buttons to import data click some
buttons to pre-process the data
and i use a lot of excel and a lot of
text editors
so my start was not starting from a
programming background so mine was more
like a so let's say like a data analyst
um
so you're you're probably using like uh
packages
uh ready to use software like spss
microsoft excel and so
my start in doing coding was toward the
end of my phd studies
where i started to dabble in class class
java and then finally into python
and a little bit before python it was
matlab and then from python i hopped
into r
i fell in love with shiny package so
awesome
and then i moved back to python for this
youtube channel
and and also for some of the data
science projects that we do
for our research and my youtube journey
started last year
and so in a nutshell my daughter
suggested that i should start a youtube
channel
and then i took some time to overcome
the procrastination
overcome the impostor syndrome and then
finally hit the record button and then
one year later and here i am today
and i find this journey an awesome
journey you get to be
a lot of like-minded individuals awesome
people like yourself richard
and it's awesome to be here
yeah you know i was going to poke you
about uh telling the story about how you
got into youtube because i knew that
story but i wanted my audience to hear
it because that's really an awesome
that's really an awesome story uh i'm
right there with you
like personally i i did the same thing
with overcoming imposter syndrome and
getting into uh
data science to a certain extent but
certainly into youtube and it's
something
that i wish i'd done uh significantly
earlier than i did because i learned
tons as i've
as i've done myself could you talk about
how you actually landed your first
job getting paid to do data science
right so straight out of my
so so i did have my phd right after uh
graduating from bachelors and so
actually technically i did not graduate
my bachelor's
i approached a potential phd advisor
and then he accepted me into uh his lab
and then i kind of started to do some
research in the lab
and also to started to audit some
courses
before graduating my bachelor's degree
and because at the final year in the
final semester i had like
about two courses left and so i was
pretty free
and so i kind of joined early into the
phd program auditing some courses and
getting head start learning about what's
research all about
and so by the time i graduated i could
immediately start doing some preliminary
research and also
to finalize the course work and then
yeah so after that it becomes
pretty amazing to discover data science
through
biological data and i i wouldn't
know what would happen if i didn't go
come into the
into this field of biology would i
stumble upon data science
so it didn't really happen that i i
really like data science from the get-go
so it just kind of came to me as a
biologist
having to analyze big data having to
struggle with analyzing big data and so
i mean data science seems to be the
natural problem solver
and then when i was acquainted with data
science
i mean it's never been the same again so
it's an awesome field to work with we're
in
what do you think has been the bigger
passion for you do you think it's
biology or do you think it's data
science
ah okay
that's a tough question let's see
i would say at the interface so
it's purely biology uh
i'm a bit bored into the the mechanism
so i've also experimented
i've done some wet lab experiments did
some gene cloning
engineered some proteins synthesized
some compounds
so like at the interface of biology
chemistry and also informatics but what
i really like
are the data that are coming from
biology
and coming from chemistry and so it's
analyzing those
biology data chemistry data is what
fascinates me
and the thing with all of these
biological research and chemical
research is that
they have research labs have spent a lot
of money
collecting data and they might not have
analyzed the data to its full potential
so
for example if we think of it like like
a like a cup
they might have analyzed it from only
this few points
but then the other the other three
hundred and what
60 degrees
and also in statistics there's this
meta-analysis where you just pull
results from
several hundred research papers in order
to up its
uh statistical significance and so
i believe that there's huge potential
for data science in biology
and so dissecting it as one or the other
is quite difficult
and i think that
all biologists or essentially all
scientists
are essentially data scientists because
scientists they perform experiments to
generate data
and then they have to analyze the data
and
typically the data that they analyze
they might use
traditional statistical approach they
might use traditional
data visualization but then there's huge
potential
if they could expand their
their domain into machine learning into
statistical visualization i mean there's
a lot to be done there
yeah you don't know what you don't know
and i mean unless unless somebody is
around you who puts that idea into your
into your brain somebody who has
some kind of i don't want to even say
expertise with but at least
awareness of what kind of problems can
be solved with those techniques
unless somebody like that is around
you're never
i'm sure in that field going to realize
your full potential
exactly how big of data sets do you
typically
work with in that domain
yeah so the common data set so let's see
the common data source that i'm
typically working with
is derived from biological and chemical
databases so my
the big chunk of my research is on drug
discovery
computational drug discovery so
chemical libraries are in the millions
and so
but then the biological activity they're
quite
limited to a couple of thousand or ten
thousand
data points so my data is not so big
and so we could typically build a model
out of a thousand to ten thousand
compounds
and then the big data part will come
from
deploying the model and then screening
an entire chemical library of couple
millions
uh by using by applying the predictive
model that we have
created yeah
very interesting most of the time
how clean is the data that you get
is it typically ready to go you're ready
to explore it
spin visualizations up do machine
learning models um
i mean the joke in industry data science
is you spent 80 percent of your time
cleaning data and you spent the other 20
times complaining about cleaning data so
in academia i'm more
curious what does that breakdown look
like
is data more clean less clean
yeah that's a great question and so
predominantly they're unclean and so
the thing is it really depends on the
data set that you're taking it from
if you're taking it from a published
paper and then you're just reproducing
their work
by applying a new algorithm so you're
using essentially their data set that
they have already cleaned
so that is ready to be used but then if
you want to
create your own original data set which
will be more
appealing to the reviewers the peer
reviewers who will be evaluating the
research findings so if you collect your
own data set then that requires a lot of
like figuring out like what kind of data
do you want to compile
from where and let's say that you're
comparing data from different data
sources so they're
very heterogeneous so you have to make
them
in a similar format you might take a
subset of one data
set from another data set and you
combine them
and then you have to clean them you have
to find a way to
make it more homogeneous and so that
requires a lot of pre-processing
and so most of the biological data sets
that i have
we also have to do some form of feature
engineering
doing some log transformation in order
to make the distribution more
normally distributed and then
um i mean a typical data cleaning and
if we're not using coding before it
would have taken me half a year
for one project
and after using python it
greatly reduced that time and
and i i mean not only python but also r
so
imagine from half a year to 10 seconds
so we we created our own in-house
scripts in r
and then we created a web server so
a web server is not like um like just a
typical web application so
the user can just upload the data set
and click on the submit button
yeah and within a couple of seconds it
will pre-process they will clean they
will create the data set
and so what used to take half a year is
now in a couple of seconds
so we're planning to publish this work
very soon and
it greatly enhances it really augments
our
data pipeline and it makes a lot it
makes our life a lot easier
now see that's it's really interesting
you say that because there's a lot of
people out there who kind of freak out
about auto ml
and all these new automatic data
cleaning technologies
and how as those things come to more
prominence and they gain maturity
that's going to come at the expense of
certain people's jobs
right because like you said i mean if
all that work
takes a year then humans don't
necessarily have to do it anymore
but you're kind of standing on the
shoulders of giants there
right because because you don't have to
waste as much time doing that kind of
stuff
you could do cooler more inventive more
interesting things right
exactly so instead of spending on the
grunt work of cleaning the data
you could spend more time in reading
more papers
learning more algorithms trying out new
workflows
and so it's not that auto ml
or automated data pipelining
will replace data scientists it's
essentially it will
shift our focus from a more manual or
grunt work into more
creative more more advanced
i mean or even provide us more time to
learn new tools
oh yeah i know i couldn't agree more so
a lot of this is
somewhat high level certainly with
respect to projects
is it possible to describe more of the
day-to-day
uh of your uh of your life as a data
scientist
yeah so day to day um
so by day time i'm a associate professor
at a research university in thailand and
so
my typical day will involve either
teaching
doing research talking to members in the
research
lab supervising undergraduates or
graduate students being in meetings
and also work at it as an administrator
because currently i'm one of the
head of the center of data mining and
and also another is i try to block time
to learn new
tech techniques new algorithms in order
to
add novelty to research project and as a
process
i'm trying to make this
youtuber thing which is like
a full-time job that i do in the
evening and also on the weekend and so
how do i manage both at the same time so
i try to make that if i'm learning new
algorithms if i'm learning new tools or
techniques
then i try to make a video about that
and the tutorial video will
will be uploaded to my youtube channel
and at the same time i'll
be learning a new tool which i could use
in my
daytime job in the research project
so kind of like a win-win situation
that is a complete best of both worlds
like i'm right there with you
like the more i do videos the more i
like pick up on little nuances
or i realize that maybe some function
has been updated
and they're they're just these they're
it's it all comes down to these little
things that i learn every single time
that i make a video
so it's certainly educational on my end
um and i was going to ask you about that
actually with
just the ability to learn new
technologies because i think in industry
a lot of the time
everybody has a huge desire to learn new
technologies
new programming languages just things
like that just because the pressure
across the data science market as a
whole the pressure to know on
a large number of things is quite great
and it varies a lot i think in industry
for how much you're actually able to
learn inside of your
particular job because you're not there
to learn
you're there to provide value you're
there to contribute to a project
so i i was really curious how much
time and to what extent
you're able to spend learning
technologies
yeah so one of the core components of
being a researcher is to introduce
novelty
in every research project that we're
doing
because the thing is if we send our work
for publication
the peer reviewers will look at what is
the novelty of our
research are we providing what kind of
new value what values are we providing
are we using a new data set are we
providing new insight into
how these things are happening are we
introducing a new bioinformatic tools
are we introducing a new machine
learning algorithm or a tweak to an
existing algorithm or what other
improvements are we making to the fields
and that would be appealing to the
audiences or the
readers of the research papers and so
all of this
it's kind of like an incentive and also
a pressure at the same time to
that keeps me motivated to also learn
new algorithms and tools
in order to be relevant in
publishing yeah yeah i mean that's not
that's not far off like the best
opportunities i've had in industry style
work
to learn a new technique language
whatever it is
it's because we really needed to be
innovative in some way shape or form
we couldn't do one just something that's
been done over and over again it had to
be something that's right
new and creative so that's that's really
interesting that uh
that's that's similar
yeah you know there's a uh there's a
medium article on that
that talks about going from academia to
industry and data science
and it made a point which is pretty
interesting to me like it made a
comparison
saying people in industry they tend to
work on a problem
for a few months and then they get to
where it's
good enough then they move on to
something else which i find that to be
generally true like you have to to a
certain extent you ask yourself
what is this a two week problem a two
month problem a two year problem
and rarely are you gonna work on
something for uh for two years
now the description they gave of
academic data science
said that you're basically spending
months or even years on a particular
problem
uh making your solution better and
better and better and optimizing it
now that's what the medium article said
do you agree or disagree with that
yeah um i'm not sure maybe that's
in another situation uh but for my own
situation
i think it's much similar to industry
that you have mentioning that you were
mentioning about
um so most of the projects that we're
doing is more
student or researcher-centric so members
of my research
lab each member would be working on
their own projects
and then i would be involved in helping
to
analyze the results or maybe providing
some suggestion
and so each of the members will have
their own projects
and so yeah they will be
responsible for you know like creating
uh planning envisioning what kind of
direction that they want to go through
and each project will typically take
about no more than four to six months in
order to be competitive because
if it's longer then someone else around
the world i mean it could be anyone
will publish something similar to what
we're doing and then that will render
our project pretty much irrelevant yeah
and we see that a lot and so it's kind
of like a race against time
to publish it to be the first to publish
that you know that niche area
that we wanted to explore yeah so it's
not that works
or in a very long-term project like
spending two years
optimizing a method i mean sure
pretty much we're we're working on this
pareto principle
and i'm sure kenji and and you you're
also working on that as well
so we try to spend minimal time like
maybe 20
of our effort to get as much like 80 of
the project to be finished
and then we'll polish it off to a
certain degree that is
you know it's workable and it has solved
the issue
and it's ready to be published i mean
all of the
major potential potential work blocks
are solved
and but but most of the projects that
are
refining the remainder 20 i mean that
might take a couple of years to make it
perfect i mean i i don't think
any project would be perfect because
solutions can come
you know like in in many ways it's kind
of like coding
you could solve the same problem using
hundreds of possible
solutions so i i guess
we're trying to be as efficient as
possible and we're trying to
weight the cost to the time and the cost
it takes
to complete so not too long not too
short
so we're trying to find a sweet spot for
that and normally
no more than half a year on a single
project
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah
i mean yeah from based on what you
described i don't think that's too
different i mean like from from how
industry is like what you said a pareto
principle sort of thing
um yeah i mean i i can totally relate to
that
now the other thing is do you think
or has it been your experience it's not
necessarily as important to have the
best
written code necessarily like best
coding practices
aren't necessarily the most important
thing having the most readable code
having the most efficient code that kind
of thing kind of takes
a back seat to other priorities has that
been your experience
yeah so i agree i totally agree
so as long as the code is getting what
it's meant to be
doing then it's fine with me um
but if if we're dealing with larger data
set where timing is critical
then maybe we might need to optimize
that
so what so rr is our approach is to
get a minimal viable code
yeah to be functioning and if it's
functioning
and it's working as it's intended to be
working then
we just leave it as is and then we move
on to the next problem and then we try
to solve that
and then however if we're scaling up the
project
and then if time is an issue then we
have to figure out how can we make it
faster
should we use tpu computing should we
use parallel computing
you know so so we're trying to solve
problems
as they come and if it's working i mean
but but most importantly it should be
very well documented
at least commented like this block of
code is doing this
this block of code is doing this so that
in the future we could
pretty much make use of it like a lego
building block
so if it's modular we could reuse some
of the components in the future project
yeah so documentation and
making it work and if there's no problem
use it and
if there's a problem that we need to
deal with then
we just solve it as it comes along okay
yeah
awesome all right so yeah
i'm curious for somebody who's
maybe they're an undergrad maybe they're
starting a master's maybe they're very
early on in a phd
i personally know several people who got
a year or two into a phd program and
then they dropped out they decided that
that wasn't right for them
so somebody at that level
how do you think they should best decide
what is the best pathway for them should
they do a more academic route in data
science
like suppose they're they've heard about
data science they're super interested in
that
but the question is do you do it in more
of an academic capacity or do you
or do you move to industry do you have
any
tips for how you kind of make that
personal decision
right so so back at the time
there were no standardized pathway
to get into data science so
my pathway into data science was kind of
by luck
i kind of stumbled upon it and then i
kind of
self-taught myself through solving
small problems each step at a time
and then by solving each step
each small problem it kind of and all of
the problem if you
take a high-level view of birthside fuel
if you could categorize the problems
then
i mean they would fall into separate
categories
like okay learning this python coding
handling the
the data set pre-processing it
pre-processing the data it's like one
cluster
model building how to make the model
more efficient more
predictive it's one how to interpret the
model how to make sense of it how to
provide value to to the data
how to allow biologists chemists
or a non-technical person to understand
the implications
of the model yeah and so all of these
are pretty distinct
and i would say they're pretty modular
and so
and then from my own pathway it's
pretty much i stumbled upon it problem
by problem
and solving it one by one and then it
and then i mean it's pretty unstructured
if you come to think of it yeah and for
those
newcomers to the field i would say it
requires
great passion and also discipline
and also dedication and also
frustration because you know like when
when you're
debugging codes when you're in a
situation when you're
you're encountering problems so you're
feeling uncomfortable
so i guess to become comfortable with
the uncomfortable
and i mean data science is not a clear
path
but but nowadays it's becoming more or
less structured
so there are a lot of great resources
for you to learn data science like what
data cap 365 data science data quests
and then most of the universities are
having
very good structured programs and they
even have a bachelor's of science degree
in data science
and jamin lee from import data he has
also graduated data science
bachelor's degree and i mean there's
bachelor's master's and now phd in data
science and business analytics
even machine learning applied machine
learning applied data science
so the field is expanding it's maturing
and it's getting a bit easier to to to
get into data science because of the
expanding resources that are available
so
i would say for those who want to get
into data science
there's ample opportunity a lot of free
resources out there
like coursera x for example so
pick one as uh richard you have also
said
for learning pick up r or python so
because when there's
so many options a common problem that
you might encounter is
you don't you don't decide because when
there's too many options
you're pretty much having this decision
fatigue
you're tired of should i go with a b c
and then you're like okay i'm not gonna
decide so
but don't overthink it choose one and
then just move on to the next
and by stumbling upon the problem from
the first option
you might you might figure that it works
for you
or it might not work for you and then
you could decide again
so let the situation take you so
don't overthink it and just get a head
start to start today if you want to get
started in data science
yeah i mean just to piggyback off a few
things you just said there
you're right there's so many resources
available now and that there's
there's so many that it can cause a
decision fatigue right
and that's why i think you get a lot of
people asking what are the best books
i should read what are the best youtube
channels i should watch one of the best
machine learning algorithms i should get
really familiar with and
i mean like you said the path for data
science is going to look somewhat
different for every single person
i think we are getting a little bit more
structure now which is
which is a very good thing because
people don't necessarily
thrive in super unstructured
environments like people like
like some degree of order and balance
and structure
so like the way i always try to put it
together like the way i try to think
about it is when i
when i recommend what people should
learn is i try to kind of serve the
most the highest percentage of people
possible right
and so we talked about this in the uh
conversation
that we did on your channel but i've
recommended that people start by number
one learning statistics
number two learning sql number three
learning one of our or python
because you're going to have to do
those things or all those things in i'd
say the majority
of data science jobs out there and it's
about you get
good at one thing at least you had that
strength going for you like personally
i don't know if you've seen uh the show
parks and rec you know you've heard of
um
or you know the character ron swanson he
says
don't half answer a bunch of things
whole ass one thing
that's totally my philosophy with with
data science too
so i guess my final question for you
would be
let's say um to some of these people who
get on the data science subreddit and
they ask
uh i want to get into data science but i
have no math background
no statistics background no nothing no
programming background nothing
where do i start what do you say to that
person
yeah so actually i made a video and i've
written a medium article
called strategies for learning data
science
so i would recommend similar to what you
are suggesting as well
so obviously the first thing and also i
made a
i've drawn an infographic on the eight
skill sets to
becoming a data scientist and also a
video about that as well
so maybe i could also share that in one
of your comments on your channel
yeah and so i mean there's many paths
i mean let's say that if there's
eight skill sets which i have analyzed
the entire links in
and then i clustered them into eight
skill sets
so one of them is data pre-processing
data munching you could call it data
wrangling and so that will
require you to you know compile your
data to rate your data
clean the data and make it higher
quality
more more structured so to say and
another would be to
embrace and pick up a programming
language
and it could be r or python as you have
already mentioned
and then be familiar with some of the
major libraries or packages that will
allow you to get through 80
of the data science projects so
obviously the first one would be to
learn about pandas
or data frame for r pandas for
python use pick up a machine learning
library
like in r it could be carrots in python
it could be effective learn
and if you're into deploying your models
in order to have
stakeholders or customers to
visualize the data or play around with
the insights from the data
then you could learn and use shiny or r
or you could also learn and pick up
streamlib for python
and more advanced would be to learn
flask
in order to deploy a web application or
make an api of that
and so it's about learning the tools of
the trade
and using the libraries or packages that
are
giving you superpowers in data science
allowing you to do most of the tasks
and then once you work your way up there
then you could embrace
with deep learning and other uh
text pre-processing or text mining
approaches natural
language processing computer vision so
this really depends on
which niche area of data science that
you want to work with
and so this also depends on the type of
data
that you're working with will it be
images will it be
streaming data will it be like a typical
like a csv file would it be a sql
database you know so all of this is very
it's really dependent on the the area
that you're coming from
the company that you're wanting to work
in and
yeah and aside from that is to do data
science so at the end of every video i
would say best way to learn this science
is do data science because
by solving projects you'll know which
are your
weak points and then you could embrace
that learn it
learn about their solutions that you
could solve
the same problem and by doing more
projects you'll pick up more experience
and then you'll recognize at the get-go
like this problem needs this
solution this problem is this solution
so
if you solve 100 project aim for as much
project to solve and work on
as much as possible and another is to
is to share the completed project onto
github
and also make a portfolio website if you
can talk about the project
you mentioned in the video that we have
collaborated
that when you're describing a project
you need to tell what is the
significance of the data what is the
significance of the project what
approach did you use what is the problem
how did you tackle it what's the novelty
what's the value that
you could get out of the project that
you're working on so if you could
share all of these in the data science
portfolio website
it would be very appealing to the
employers
yeah yeah awesome
all right well that's all the questions
that i have for you so
yeah janet thanks so much for coming on
my channel appreciate uh
uh you're having this conversation here
with me i learned a lot from you and i'm
sure my audience did as well so thanks
again man
yeah thank you so much richard yeah
absolutely
so that's uh that about does it for this
so uh just all right
from uh from you guys out there uh as
always number one
uh shannon's channel is beta professor
so check that out and subscribe to it
because it's awesome
uh check out the interview that i've
done on his channel we did another
collab where i talk about some of my
uh experiences so check that one out too
on both of those videos smash the like
button because that really helps our uh
uh just channels reach a larger audience
in general
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard